cai est à 11h55 partait stress fatigue
[Rires]
[Musique]
est toujours pas de champignons étrange
c'est étrange couper l'eau ont
l'habitude ça fait comme ça toujours pas
tant pis
je leur dis bon et après le trou noir
je me suis réveillé dans le champ de la
prof toujours pas de champignons
l'étrange mais j'étais sûr que c'était
la saison je prêtais sur des 3 600 lits
cet étrange
il doit y avoir une case sur trois
personnes neuf juges
oui tu viens tu étais un peu pour tous
vas-y redit les champignons en défaut
lié à ton manque de concentration c'est
pourquoi on est ici précisément non mais
les claques aux quelqu'un rentre
si c'est encore pour me parler d'hygiène
je te rappelle que les gens à mon époque
sont très propres et à la renaissance
seulement veut enterrer le pilote de
guerre comment sa voiture ses alliés
nord pour toi donc là allons-y
[Musique]
disons très bien faisons comme ça aussi
oui aussi voilà nous sommes arrivés trop
tôt dans le futur petit rien à elle
lancé peut-être davantage puis quoi
qu'il en soit être plus nombreuses nous
rendra plus forte si c'est pierre bois
d'alain chabat
je comprends non mais je comprends mais
rien n'a vraiment pas tendre avec son
organisation les six des cyber
historiens bon mais mais j'avais une
voiture en même temps et de publication
s'était colleté être plus nombreuses on
rendra plus forte
c'est quoi
oui la dope
[Rires]
bonjour c'est pas du tout préparé c'est
un peu vénère de sambou way et si ça
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à aller sur
le site pour vous faire un don qui nous
permettra d'acheter encore j'étais comme
toi avant le relais là je sais pas quand
et si ça vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
aller sur un aussi pour faire j'étais
comme toi avant ouvre les yeux
yes papa tu as fait une dernière fois
n'hésitez pas à me suis aussi comme
perrin dont j'étais comme toi avant
ouvrons les yeux on repart vraiment
jusque là un tintin a lyon on bouge pas
alors on se remet vite
yes soit 20 comme ça ouais à deux trois
pirates
donc je pense qu'elle est dans un bar je
pense que j'ai pu voir c'est bien on
recommence et dernière fois excusez moi
alors va falloir que tu te mettes un peu
plus sur la droite
justin on leur fait mme nooy robin était
parfait c'est justin un peu parce
qu'elle te cache en fait un enfant à
l'hélium à la malaisie maintenant on
entend ça brûle pas coupé peut-être non
maintenant on attend juste non mais y'a
pas de mal
vous avez le droit d'habiter là allez on
se concentre on se recentre saraka nuage
blanc ton plan 3 seyfoullah vient c'est
bien foutues quand même cette histoire
ouais il faut improviser l'oréal aurait
pu faire un effort sur la tenue mais
comment ça et babeth eu des malades
obodji top a vu ta gueule non
bagis sur toi à boire on dirait talent
de cet agnostique et papa qu'il bull ça
fait tellement ici parce que je m'en
suis servi bon ça arrive à tout le monde
de le dire épisode 1 séquence une blanc
1 prise 2 caps
obasi qui a fait ça moi oui tu poses des
questions
allô allô c'est astrid edith walla de
coire cimer historiens comme ça peut ben
je sais pas première du coup
manon personnes s'arrêtent pour moi ça
tourne la caméra
[Musique]
non mais je veux dire par contre annonce
peut-être non je sais je sais pas le
3-5-2 13,3 c'est vraiment en train de le
graet et tu vas parler gauche le garde
des sceaux pour le plus sain tu vas
parraitre tu vas parler mais je suis
comme dusty jusqu'à deux mètres sans
pareil tu vas parler ou je te garde
aussi jusqu'à 7 300 par les mauves n'ont
désormais fameux et que je regarde trop
mal à refaire mais pas comme tu l'enfer
du bim hi he said et bien sûr moi je
veux couper l'eau
on lance une roquette est bon on avance
baroud a juste à haute voix haute et en
bouchon auquel élèves et à la
descendante alcoolique et avant dans
cette rue là je te vois bref tu nous
emmènes 23ème siècle on parle à sa
patronne et rentrer chez nous débite
richie porte oui mais comment nous a dit
trouver à voir c'est peut-être duras et
après après un centre cédric aguet
disparaît moi je dis on verra tout ce
qui dépasse jusqu'à ce qu'ils en plus
donc je veux bien parler en fait je suis
un peu douillet donc si on pouvait
éviter tout ce que vous venez de dire ça
m'arrangerait j'ai pas je suis en train
de changer en train de monde enregistré
est là mon cas contraire c'est pas bon
alors mais pas moi pour moi ok elle
[Rires]
[Musique]
appuie sur ses atouts sur ses appuis sur
ces c'est parti
hop
godefroy
aliénor tu connaisses gueule alors je
suis content de mon chien ce que c'est
pas facile on va refaire un coupe faim
on la refait expliquant qu'un patch
notes au milieu du couloir s'il vous
plaît juste seconde milieu de couloir
justin vient d'un milieu avancer reculer
roquet encore gamin comme ça sur
l'ouvèze voilà là vous êtes net paquet
7,09 merde que je me suis complètement
forêt sur la crise au point ancêtres
numéro de maillot numéro dans cette rude
hiver rôdeur je peux même vous oubliez
tout ça en vidéo fait ça tout le temps
et vous ancêtres je pense à me faire
quoi dans cette histoire c'est bon c'est
bon
wec et en assistant au là incroyable à
tous bah c'est un tout qui veulent
laisser godefroy l'offre et godefroy
alors comment était venise godefroy de
hobbit
mais il a dû manger mais manger six
séquences un plan un prix un [ __ ] je
fais chier
ouais d'accord elles sont un peu barré
mais font mal à personne au 21ème siècle
j'ai à peine sucrée sa soeur de son
canapé d'habitude par contre je pourrais
vous être utile je n'ai réussi du fruit
quand elles auront le double quand même
été pendant cinq ans et les parfums loi
d'accord c'est un peu ma rainey font mal
à personne au 21ème siècle
j'ai à peine si le prêt ça sort de son
canapé d'habitude par contre je pourrais
vous être utile elle a eu des mots aussi
je suis un des sont autant de talent fou
et je me satire c'est que nous avons un
accord non faut pas que tu te lèves
parce qu'on te voit plus ok
pourtant dans doctor who la plupart du
temps ça passe j'imagine qu'il a envoyée
d'en faire des tonnes de questions
peut-être fait le plus pour toi m'a
répondu que non mais c'est pas du tout
la peur je croyais qu'elle s'était
planté et après c'est pas grave sourit
allez go go go go go le met à la page
donc à prendre lui plus sur l'épaule
parce qu'en fait du coup tu t'étais s'en
cache pas mon temps on voit pas la main
en fait attend lève toi ma chambre
désolé je vais pas refaire
rick hallet attendez je veux pas partir
encore une fois attendez je veux pas
partir yes
c'est bon on entendu montbard mouillé ou
pas mais je le reverrai plus jamais un
choc
je ne sais pas si ça va se voir
du coup qu il ya moyen de shalio si tu
ne penses pas
3 6 mais non non enfin je serai le
premier pirate de l'espace belge mais
c'est encore pire mais je sais pas sur
quoi tu va lancer des frites et des
pistolets sera moules frites et abordage
[Rires]
enlever leur est flou parce que du coup
ça te blesse on le voit ouais
l'antiquité tête ou alors plus dans ta
barbe
c'est bête jeu je crois pendant cette
répartie en vacances il est plus touché
lui gsm et le froid perdu mon appareil
[Rires]
il s'est fait se porter sur le côté
ses compagons tués mais voilà si tu as
aussi de toutes versions la prison pour
ça en fait c'est la faute à l'uci ne
rien n'est encore sûr mais mais c'est
pas possible voyage temporel de baird
hockey ont la double ça va mieux
ok allez essayer un maximum ne pas
bouger je sais que c'est compliqué mais
mais mais ce paquet de merde
le 31 août 22 on agit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]